trois sénateurs démocrates ont écrit au
secrétaire d'état mac pompéo et au
secrétaire au trésor stephen low chine
pour exiger que l'administration trump
impose immédiatement et avec force des
sanctions contre le gouvernement et les
citoyens russes soupçonnés d'implication
dans la supposée ingérence électorale
l'administration trump a la possibilité
d'imposer des sanctions pour l'ingérence
dans nos élections
elle n'a pas besoin de nouveaux outils
législatifs ou d'approbation
notre message est clair secrétaire
minchin imposer des sanctions
immédiatement quoi que ce soit de loin
reviendrait à vous dédouaner de votre
responsabilité de protection et de
défense des états unis envers cette
grave menace contre notre sécurité
nationale et contre l'intégrité de notre
processus électoral et les trois élus
signataires ne sont pas les premiers
venus
chuck schaeffer est le leader de la
minorité démocrate au sénat tandis que
bob menendez et sherrod brown sont
respectivement en charge des comités
sénatoriaux des relations étrangères et
bancaire les qu'elle supervise la
politique de sanctions quant à la
réaction de moscou à l'envoi de cette
lettre elle n'a pas tardé l'ambassade de
russie aux etats-unis exprime sa
profonde préoccupation face à la
tournure des spéculations sur l'
ingérence présumée de la russie dans les
élections américaines
il est particulièrement frappant de voir
comment les forces politiques à
washington
exploite ce mythe pour en tirer un gain
politique faire des allégations non
liées à la russie totalement infondées
et fictive devient une bien mauvaise
tradition politique aux etats unis
lorsqu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
d'arguments lorsqu'il n'ya pas
suffisamment d'outils pour mener un
combat politique sur le plan domestique
ont fait appel à ce facteur russe c'est
une triste réalité à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés depuis de nombreuses
années mais au fait que contient ce
brief du renseignement américain on y
apprend via les médias
d'outre-atlantique que moscou semble se
livrer à des campagnes de désinformation
et de propagande pour aider à la fois le
favori pour l'investiture démocrate
bernie sanders mais aussi le président
sortant donald trump qui entend bien se
faire réélire au mois de novembre
un récit qui repose entièrement sur des
sources anonymes non vérifiables et qui
est malheureusement amené à se répéter
selon le porte parole du kremlin il
s'agit là de nouveaux messages
paranoïaque qui malheureusement seront
de plus en plus nombreux à la proche des
élections
bien sûr cela n'a rien à voir avec la
vérité
alors que la soi-disant ingérence russe
est de nouveau bondi aux états unis à la
proche de la présidentielle moscow
estime que cette pseudo menace de
l'extérieur est instrumentalisée à des
fins de politique intérieure
[Musique]